well maybe you could tell me something
about myself i would love to
do i have permission to pull a card for
you yes you do have permission to pull a
card okay shuffle shuffle
yep see you're shuffling that sound pull
down your sound that sound you're
hearing is the shuffling of cards oh yes
okay all right this is exciting i don't
know what's gonna happen oh my gosh okay
you got this beautiful six of cups okay
i'll describe it it's like there's
describe the picture there's two two
children it's a it's a very sunny happy
card one of the one of the children is
offering the other
a bouquet of flowers okay
and this is this there's a real sense of
nostalgia in this card so i would say
it's maybe somebody from your past has
been on your mind maybe you need to to
connect with them right now let me think
past
nope
okay uh no no no i'm kidding um
well that's just such a broad statement
so yes
often there are people in our past that
are on our minds
um
i drew a line when i became famous in
1993 i decided to cut all ties with
everyone before then
that's what you're supposed to do
harrison ford told me that's what you're
supposed to do and i did it so i don't
speak to
i've not spoken to my parents my
brothers my sisters anyone from uh
pre-fame had to go
well and this is the other thing you
need to offer an olive branch to
somebody it's time for forgiveness wow
so yeah well if only there was someone
close to me who i probably owed an
apology to
who
okay so sona
sona is the high priestess that's the
card you just pulled and sona i do think
of you as a high priestess yeah you're
often high you uh
no i don't apologize yet until i know
uh patty what do i have to apologize to
sona for do you think oh my god i will
tell you i i know what you have to
apologize to her for what happened for
calling her bad on one of the previous
podcasts one of you wait wait did you
say one yeah could you say one of the
previous budgets patty
i have uh demeaned her work ethic in
every episode of the podcast
but you specifically called her bad and
yeah although i did understand where you
were coming from yeah well patty come on
so no not being bad but in in your
rationalization of it so but i digress
she uses my name to get like
reservations and drinks at restaurants
that i'm not going to that's bad that is
bad she brought a dog to a restaurant
that doesn't allow dogs because she knew
that i was going to be
joining her there and she thought the
wait staff won't say anything if conan
o'brien's there this these are the
actions of a terrible person he makes
large groups of people laugh at me and
then he forces me to high-five him
immediately after he's made fun of me
yeah so he he does that he had everybody
calling me a vampire for the first like
three years that i worked for him do you
not drink the blood of the living so
that you can live forever do you not
sona i don't actually i don't do that
because i'm not a vampire i don't even
know you know why it started because i
was speaking armenian to my grandma and
he said it sounded like i was arguing
with dracula it didn't sound
yeah
and it just sounded it sounded it
sounded that's what it sounded like to
me it sounded like dracula was trying to
talk to a fellow vampire and trying to
get him down on the price of a used car
that's what it sounded like
apologize
and so i just i didn't know so i came
out and i was legitimately uh describing
what i had heard and so listen i will
say sona i'm looking at your zoom
background i don't see a single crucifix
hanging on the wall
and guess what you're right everyone
who's not a vampire has massive
crucifixion
several times i've uh
visited and of course i was raised very
catholic uh and come from a very
catholic background and family i've
given sona crucifixes said here this is
for your home i picked this up in rome
it's really beautiful and she goes
[Music]
[Laughter]
and knocks it out of my hand and then it
bursts into flames